- This is what gives me energy,
saying I'm going to do
something, putting it out there
for the world to see and
then going out and doing it.
I'm a mother fucking war
horse from all angles,
not just in the gym.
There's a lot of bad stuff
going on in the country.
A lot of people are struggling,
everybody's struggling
but since them seeing me
chase this dream, it's giving
them an energy and I see a
new lease on life in them.
- He's an Irish professional
mixed martial artist.
During his career, he's
competed as a featherweight,
lightweight, and welterweight.
He's the first fighter in UFC
history to hold two titles
in different weight
classes at the same time.
He's Conor McGregor and
here's my take on his
top ten rules for success, volume two.
And as always guys, if
you hear something that
really resonates with
you, please leave it down
in the comments below, put
quotes around it as well,
so other people can be inspired.
Also, when you write it
down, you're much more
likely to lock it in for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(inspirational music)
- Stripping that all back
to the start of your career,
a man with a dream, training
in the gym day in and day out,
if somebody said to you
you'll be as successful
as you are now, what would
you have said back then?
(clears throat)
- I believe ya, that's
what I would've said
because I did believe, I believed in it.
I had very few people who told me that.
I had a small, small,
small group of people
that would tell me something like that.
Other than that, it was
just me telling myself
so if someone came up
to me and told me that
all the way back then,
I'd say you're damn right.
(soft upbeat music)
I was thrown into a plumbing trade.
Didn't give a shit about plumbing,
didn't know anything about plumbing.
I just went on that site because culture
told me that that's what I have to do.
I had done it for awhile
and then I realized
this is not what I want to do.
If this is not what I want to do,
then what the fuck am I doing it for?
And I walked out, 18 months in maybe.
- There was a concern for
all of us, for his mother
and for other, we didn't know what he
was going to do, to be honest with you.
- Earlier on, obviously I
didn't know what it was.
I couldn't look to my mother and say,
"Hey, this Irish man done it,
I'm going to follow in this footsteps,"
because there was no footsteps.
I had to create my own
footsteps and follow them.
They were a little unsure
at first but they support me
and they know I would do it.
If I said I would do
it, then I would do it.
- Yeah, I don't just knock them
out, I pick the round John.
Yeah, I said this, I'm
sure yous are probably
all thinking this guy is
talking absolute dribble.
He's not going to do what
he says he's going to do.
Yous are probably all
sitting there thinking that
but now here we are again, and I've done
what I said I was going to do.
I feed off this, I feed off this.
I love this stuff, this
is what gives me energy.
Saying I'm going to do
something, putting it out there
for the world to see and
then going out and doing it.
There's no better feeling
in the world than that
and it's as easy as that.
Say what you're going
to do and go and do it.
When you're chasing your
dream and when you're
working hard, chasing something you love,
and completely dedicated, it just happens.
You can't really notice it, you know,
even still to this day.
I'm in an amazing position
in my life but I'm
still walking like I'm not, like I'm not.
I'm still walking like
I'm not in this position.
- [Interviewer] Absolutely.
- I'm still walking like
none of this is even...
You know what I mean?
It's just something I
love to do and I just
keep pushing and keep working hard.
I can't pinpoint an exact moment for you
but if anything, I always
felt like it was happening
way back then and now it is happening,
but now I almost feel
like it's not happening.
Do you know what I mean?
I want to push to something else.
I'm always striving to push forward.
Hard work pays, I put in
a hell of a lot of work
all throughout this
build up and the fight.
I pumped out more content than anybody,
more content than Fox,
more content than ESPN,
more content than BT Sport, more content
than anybody on the mic,
more than my own channels.
You know what I mean?
I'm a mother fucking work
horse from all angles,
not just in the gym.
I'm building this media empire myself.
We pumped out the content and
I'm very proud of how it went.
The consistently daily
movies I was releasing
from like a month ago, every single day,
nobody's doing that so
I'm very proud of it.
Work pays, hard work
pays, and we put in the
fucking work and that's
why I'm sitting at the top.
I put it all on the line, I show up,
I perform, and I get
the results from that.
- Weren't you working in
the plumbing business?
- I was working in the
plumbing business at the time
and I'm trying to think,
it would have been around
that time that John ...
nah see, I had left the
plumbing business, I had
left the plumbing business.
- How bad was that?
- The plumbing?
- Yeah.
- Horrendous.
- Were you actually in the trenches?
- It was in an industrial so
it'd be like building this.
It'd be like the plumbing
that would be needed
in a place like this, six
o'clock in the morning
and I used to have to
walk for about an hour
to get to the motorway and then I'd stand
on the edge of the motorway
and wait for a bloke
to drive by so he'd give me a lift
and the motorway was getting
a renovation at the time
so it'd take me two hours,
two and a half hours,
to get to the place that
was out in the country.
Then I'd be there for ten hours working
and I was a first-year so I
was the worst of the worst,
you know, I was only a beginner.
Then two hours to get
back in the traffic again
which was a horrible, horrible time.
I was like you know what?
I don't want to do this
and then I just left
and then I just stopped
going, didn't get out of bed
and me dad was coming in
trying to beat me out of bed
and we'd have fights and
usually, for a good while,
I didn't really speak to me dad.
We just kind of stayed
away from each other.
Anytime I'd come across me dad, I'd ...
Anytime we did speak was to fight.
- You lived in his house?
- Yeah, I was only 18.
- But you didn't talk to him?
Isn't that kind of awkward?
- It wasn't, whatever, you know.
- You just didn't have
a deep relationship?
- No, but since this has happened, since
the dream has happened, since the vision
that I had has come true...
And like he went through
tough times as well
because he'd got testicular cancer
and so he got sick and all in my head,
I was thinking I done that
because he's worried about me,
he doesn't know what I'm going to do,
and all these fights that
were happening all the time.
I'm talking full on fights,
he'd come in and punch me.
- You'd punch him back?
- Yeah, we were going at it.
- Wow, what did your mom say about that
whose so protective of you?
- Yeah, I don't know, she
just stayed out of it.
- Why did it get to that point
to where he was that mad?
- Just because I was
doing absolutely nothing.
I was out getting into trouble.
- He was disappointed in you?
- Yeah, basically, he
felt like I was a waster.
I was a waster, got called that a lot.
And then once I started getting that focus
and realizing I'm going
to make this happen,
and then now that it has
happened, I'm making it happen
and I have a great
relationship with me dad.
We talk all the time and
I even see energy in him
and I see energy in me mom.
It's pressing times for a
lot of people in Ireland,
there's a lot of bad stuff
going on in the country.
A lot of people are struggling,
everybody's struggling
and since them seeing me chase this dream,
it's giving them an energy
and I see a new lease
on life in them and that
alone spurs me on even more.
So it's all just a perfect
storm that is happening for me
and that is why I have this tunnel vision
and that is why I'm willing
to kill every single
man in my path to get that belt,
just to secure the future,
my family's future.
That's what I'm doing it for.
It's hard to say, but
when I was a kid I always
visualized stadiums and even
when I was playing football,
I'd kick the ball against
the wall and pretend
that I'd scored a goal and I'd run off
and I'd be raising my hand
and visualizing an arena
full of fans and that was
something I'd done as a kid
out on me own, just running
around kicking the ball.
I'd always had these visions of something,
but I just didn't know
what it was and then
I suppose when I came to these events
and I started training and
then I came to an event,
I was like okay, this is it,
this is what I'm going to do
and now I'm doing it.
My experience is in cage wars
and all the other promotions,
not just the promotions
before that as well.
It helped prepare me
for certain situations
that you find yourself
in but you're talking.
Even fighting in the UFC and
then fighting on a McGregor
show in the UFC is leaps
and bounds different.
Everything has been a
learning experience for me
and I take everything
as a learning experience
and I look to grow from
it and you know what?
That's why I keep growing.
The Irish people might understand more.
A young boy dreaming of
putting on the Irish jersey
or dreaming of putting on his
favorite ball team's jersey
and that crest, and lifting that club.
This is my crest, these gloves right here,
these UFC gloves, you know?
To be the first man to put
these one, to lace these up.
They're going to do the job and honestly,
no one can take that away
from me, no matter what.
Honestly, I don't mean to be disrespectful
but I don't care about nothing else.
I don't know about nothing else.
I don't even waste my
time with something else.
Just don't listen, I'm talking shit
but if I talk about this, if
I talk about honor in combat,
if I talk about the human anatomy,
the way the human body moves...
I've been listening to
laughter all my whole career.
them laugh my whole career.
They've been laughing.
What, an Irish man winning a cage war?
Oh hell no, you serious, an Irish man?
An Irish man win a fight in the UFC?
Hell no, laugh, laughs all around.
Okay, you got a win, now he
wants to win a world title.
Hell no, he's all talk,
he's all hype, he's a joke.
Laughter all around at the joker
and then the joker goes
and wins the world title.
Now he wants to win a second world title?
More laughter.
Listen, the sound of laughter
and the sound of doubt,
motivates me so I'm
enjoying that, I seek that.
I don't feel no doubt or I don't feel that
going to fight any of these
other UFC bums right now.
They need to rise up.
Right now, they're down there.
I've got this situation where people
are truly doubting me like they doubted me
at the very, very beginning
and that's motivating for me.
That's what's going to drive me to the gym
when I need to go to the
gym to put in that work
to get that win so that's
where we're at right now.
- Jose Aldo backed out.
He was going to fight you, backed out,
and said it was due to a rib injury
but he's been cleared
to fight by a doctor.
What do you think happened?
- I mean the man is running scared.
I cannot force a man who is not
willing to step in to fight.
I cannot force him into
the octagon to face me
but really, I cannot hold
any grudge towards him
because I would not
want to face me either.
(crowd applauds)
I was going to destroy him.
- You were going to destroy
him and you think it was pure
fear is the reason he backed out?
- He has been medically cleared to fight.
Doctors have looked at him, examined him.
He went and saw a gynecologist
and it turns out it was
just a little period pain.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know what you
think of our volume 2 series.
Let me know in the comments below.
Also, I'd love to know what did Conor say
that had the biggest impact on you?
Which clip resonated the
most with you and why?
And what are you going
to take from this video
and apply immediately somehow
to your life or your business?
Leave it down in the comments.
I'm super curious to find out.
Finally, I want to give a
quick shout out to Rames Rosas.
Thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book "Your One Word."
It really, really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying the book.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever
you're one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.